Every job has that one coworker everyone avoids
like the plague.
Well, it turns out that working in Hollywood
is just like any other job, and some celebrities
have earned a serious reputation among their
co-stars—so much so, that other actors don't
ever want to work with them again.
Let's take a look at some of the most infamous
co-star beefs, and how they got started.
Julia Roberts vs Nick Nolte
Costars in the 1994 romcom I Love Trouble,
Roberts and Nolte didn't mesh well onscreen
or off.
Reportedly, the constant quarreling got so
bad that director Charles Shyer resorted to
filming some of their scenes separately to
keep them apart as much as possible.
"You have zero chance of scoring here, trust
me, move on."
"I'm sorry, where did you say you're from,
Bitchville?"
While shooting, Roberts told the New York
Times that Nolte was...
"Completely disgusting [and] seems go out
of his way to repel people."
Nolte later shot back,
"It's not nice to call someone 'disgusting.'
But she's not a nice person.
Everyone knows that."
James Franco vs Tyrese Gibson
Much of the 2006 military drama Annapolis
centers around a planned boxing tournament
for the U.S. Naval Academy.
"There ain't no way I'm letting someone finish
this year, whose not worthy of this academy."
"I'm not quitting."
But Franco took his method acting way too
far.
According to co-star Tyrese Gibson, Franco
actually landed punches during rehearsal.
Gibson told Elle,
"The dude was full-on hitting me.
I was always like, 'James, lighten up, man.
We're just practicing.'
He never lightened up."
Franco denies ever hitting Gibson, but admitted
to GQ,
"I was probably a jerk."
But the admission wasn't good enough for Gibson,
who told Playboy in 2007,
"I never want to work with him again, and
I'm sure he feels the same way.
It felt very personal.
It was f—ed up."
Shannen Doherty vs everyone
The notoriously difficult Shannen Doherty
reportedly nearly came to blows with her Beverly
Hills 90210 castmate Jennie Garth.
Fighting became so bad that fellow 90210 vet
Tori Spelling revealed to Lifetime in 2015
that she even got her father, Aaron Spelling,
who produced the show, to fire Doherty.
Then, four years later, Doherty and castmate
Alyssa Milano beefed on the set of another
Aaron Spelling production, Charmed.
According to Milano,
"There were definitely some rough days…
it was very much sort of like high school."
Over a decade has passed since Doherty's departure
from Charmed, and it seems she and Milano
have finally buried the hatchet.
When Doherty was diagnosed with breast cancer
in 2016, Milano said,
"I told her my concern and how everyone was
on her side and we're all supporting her,
and she was very appreciative that I reached
out."
Richard Gere vs Sylvester Stallone
For years, there's been an apparent behind-the-scenes
feud between Gere and Stallone.
Stallone finally explained the beef between
the actors with Ain't It Cool News in 2006,
saying Gere had originally been cast as the
lead in 1974's The Lords of Flatbush.
But since Gere and Stallone clashed immediately
during filming, Gere was replaced by Perry
King.
Stallone recalls Gere getting too rough during
fight rehearsals and spilling greasy food
all over Stallone's pants.
Sly claims,
"To this day he seriously dislikes me.
He even thinks I'm the individual responsible
for the gerbil rumor.
Not true… but that's the rumor."
"Just relax, amigo, you wanna talk, we'll
talk.
I'm a sucker for good conversation"
Robert Downey Jr. vs Terrence Howard
Howard isn't shy about talking about his falling
out with Iron Man co-star Robert Downey Jr.
"I'm not mad, I'm indifferent."
"I told him I was sorry, you don't respect
yourself so I know you don't respect me."
In 2013, Howard appeared on Watch What Happens
Live, and claimed that while the studio had
initially signed him to a three-movie deal,
"They came to me with the second and said
'Look, we will pay you one-eighth of what
we contractually had for you, because we think
the second one will be successful with or
without you."
He went on to blame Downey, a.k.a., the former
"friend" whom he'd helped book Iron Man in
the first place.
"I called my friend, that I helped get the
first job, and he didn't call me back for
three months."
Three years later, the pair finally patched
things up and reunited at the 2016 wedding
of director Brian Grazer.
Kevin Smith vs Bruce Willis
While Smith and Willis had no issues acting
together in Live Free or Die Hard, the two
hit the skids on the set of 2010's Cop Out,
in which Willis starred and Smith directed.
Smith had even taken a massive pay cut in
order to work with Willis on the film.
But unfortunately, superstars sometimes come
with super egos.
"It just went south.
Right away.
The whole thing went south, Jack."
Smith later described the Cop Out directing
experience with Willis as "soul-crushing"
and credits Willis' co-star Tracy Morgan with
helping him get through filming:
"Were it not for Tracy, I might've killed
myself or someone else in the making of that
movie."
"He's just talkin, talkin talkin, and the
whole time I'm thinking, that's David f---ing
Addison, man"
In his 2012 memoir Tough Sh*t, Smith said
that Willis,
"Turned out to be the unhappiest, most bitter,
and meanest emo-b*tch I've ever met at any
job I've held down.
And mind you, I've worked at Domino's Pizza."
Ouch.
Julianna Margulies vs Archie Panjabi
On the set of The Good Wife, an ongoing feud
between stars Julianna Margulies and Archie
Panjabi caused tension for years before Panjabi
left the show.
While their characters were close friends,
the actresses were not.
"I don't have friends."
"You were a friend, and you lied to me."
The pair were not actually filmed together
for a whopping 51 episodes, and most on-screen
communication between their characters took
place over the phone.
When Panjabi left the show, she and Margulies
finally had a scene together, but, yep, it
was also filmed separately, with some crafty
post-production.
Bette Davis vs Joan Crawford
It was one of the most famous Hollywood rivalries
of all time—so much so that FX even developed
a series centered on the feud.
"And action!"
"Oww, god damn!"
"I barely touched her."
These two queens of the silver screen had
it in for each other as early as the 1930s,
when Davis starred in the film Dangerous alongside
Franchot Tone.
Davis was soon smitten with the actor, but
Crawford won that round, marrying Tone soon
after the movie wrapped production.
Later, Davis famously remarked,
"[Crawford] slept with every male star at
MGM except Lassie."
The rivalry came to a fever pitch in the 1960s,
when Davis and Crawford co-starred in Whatever
Happened to Baby Jane?
When only Davis was nominated for an Oscar
for her role in the film, Crawford was livid.
"God I hate this night!"
Crawford campaigned against Davis and managed
to steal the limelight for herself—when
she accepted the Oscar on behalf of winner
Anne Bancroft, who was unable to attend the
ceremony.
Producer William Frye recalled Davis' reaction
at an Oscars after-party.
Davis filled a glass with scotch all the way
to the rim, telling Frye it was for Crawford.
When Frye told her that Crawford drank vodka,
and not scotch, Davis replied,
"I don't care what she drinks.
This is going into her f—ing face."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!